thomas baroin 21 ans a profité de sa
pause déjeuner pour faire un détour au
magasin de jouets de montigny le
bretonneux
son objectif trouver un cadeau pour son
cousin à quelques heures de noël
j'aime bien me prendre à la dernière
minute à noël c'est pas très
représentatif pour moi donc
donc j'ai fait jamais vraiment guère
fait plus juste avant je me dis que ce
serait bien que j'achète quelque chose
donc je vais toujours de la même façon
et je pense que c'est pas près de
changer
au total ce sont trois français sur 10
qui viennent acheter leurs cadeaux la
dernière semaine
un achat de dernière minute qui peut
ressembler à un véritable casse tête
pour les clients la fête massés au
téléphone comme ça on est de la choisir
un temps backès que son fils il aimerait
sa fille mes enfants on échange les
idées quoi en fait
parce que c'est pas évident ils ont tous
les enfants aujourd'hui je vous laisse
j'ai quand même pressé avoir un
casse-tête également pour les boutiques
ce magasin de jouets qui enregistre 15 %
de clients supplémentaires dans les
derniers jours se retrouvent en rupture
de stock sur plusieurs produits
1 trois jours de noël bien sûr y'a la
rupture sur certains produits ça c'est
sûr donc après soit on continue à
chercher désespérément au foyer sera
mature aux choses aillent dans cette
chocolaterie de montigny le bretonneux
c'est également la course aux derniers
achats de noël
cette période de l'année représente 50%
du chiffre d'affaires annuel de la
boutique avec des pics à 15000 euros la
journée beaucoup plus de monde donc on
est quand même hier on était sur une
journée à 180 clients jours aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on va faire à peu près 200
clients jour demain on va faire 220-230
et jusqu'au samedi comme ça on va
montrer presque à 300 clients jours
derniers achats programmés pour ce week
end la carte bleue risque encore de
chauffer alors voilà pour vous souhaite
de bonnes fêtes à bout bonnes fêtes de
noël cagnato monsieur poulpe ou revoir
au revoir monsieur